répétition grandeur nature avant les
championnats de france les championnats
régionaux de gymnastique artistique
organisée à guyancourt ce week end
permettent au gymnase d'obtenir leur
billet pour la demi finale des
championnats de france
la plupart des athlètes guyancourt
toiles sont habitués aux joutes
nationales
ce rendez vous est donc l'occasion
d'essayer de nouveaux enchaînements mais
parfois à risque pour l'instant ça s'est
bien passé mais j'ai là ces nouveautés
je suis tombé faut aller jusqu'au bout
d'un coeur d'un gymnase guyancourt toit
se préparent à cette compétition depuis
début août et le stage de reprise et les
performances sont au rendez vous je suis
content dans l'ensemble parce qu'on a
amené des modifications par rapport aux
mouvements de la d'après compétitions
précédentes dont il ya encore un peu
d'incertitude et de stress par rapport à
ça mais dans l'ensemble sur l'engagement
il ya une bonne chose bon quelques
petites erreurs sur ce premier agrès
mais là on profite du repos pour
récupérer cette compétition c'est aussi
l'occasion de faire naître des vocations
c'est beaucoup de stress pendant trois
jours son prêt par le vendredi on fait
tous le samedi ou le dimanche
mais ce qui est bien c'est que ça permet
de réunir les parents et les enfants que
des jeunes des futurs gym qui font de la
baby gym voir steve pourrait faire plus
tard et puis se disent bien pourquoi pas
moi sur les deux jours de compétition
environ 350 participantes se sont
affrontés sur le plateau trois gymnases
guyancourt toison remporté la
compétition dans leurs catégories
respectives dont jade pâtissons en
nationale b elles défendront leurs
couleurs lors des championnats de france
au mois de mai